lebanon's president Michelle lawn is due
to leave his official residence our
own's mandate will end at midnight on
Monday the 89 year old Leader's tenure
has been challenging with the financial
meltdown in the Beirut Port explosion
Parliament has so far been unable to
agree to our own successor let's bring
in Ali Hashem who's joining us from
that's in Western Lebanon so with
Allen's term coming to an end the
parliament failing to elect a successor
Ali is Lebanon heading towards a
political vacuum
15 years in the past two presidencies of
presidents
Lebanon witnessed the same situation
whereas there is uh in the parliament
failed to elect a new president or a
successor and there was a power vacuum
now the government by by tomorrow
midnight the caretaker a government that
resigned after the Parliamentary
elections back in May is going to be the
the caretaker of the whole system
however with very limited powers and
everyone is looking towards the
parliament to agree on the new on the
new candidate to vote for sadata Palace
that's behind me is going to be built
once again but it's the same with
numbers this is also Michelle Allen's
second time coming out of this Palace
Michelle on in 1990 was the head of the
military government at the end of the
Civil War and he was forced out of this
of this Palace after the Syrian Army
stormed in so these are two pictures
different pictures between 1990 and 2022
and Lebanon right now with all what's
happening over here with the political
crisis with the economic Fallout which
uh the uh lack of services Lebanese are
looking forward to see solutions for
their problems but now they are facing a
bigger problem with us there is no one
to rule them so Ali what will own legacy
be because depending on who you speak to
in Lebanon they will remember him
differently
well that is a mixed Legacy but in
general it's a better Legacy because the
term of our own saw the 2019 broadcast
the term of own also saw the financial
Fallout of the country whereas Lebanon
is maybe one of the most affected
countries in the whole world
the sound is very high behind me anyway
so Lebanon is facing a very serious
financial crisis a real electricity
crisis political crisis besides the 2020
explosion that the port of Beirut all
these are legacies that Michelle our own
stem is going to be remembered
the latest agreement with Israel on the
markings the gas field so it's also
another Legacy that Lebanese are going
to remember this term with okay Ali will
let you go for now thank you so much Ali
Hashem reporting from the presidential
Palace in babda in Lebanon thank you